this morning in our pushing-the-limit
series we take a look at a project
that's redefining the boundaries of
speed the british-based Bloodhound team
is building a car they hope will travel
more than a thousand miles an hour
that's well over the speed of sound it
would shatter the current land speed
record Charlie d'Agata took to the sky
with the cars driver
he's a former fighter jet pilot who's
training his body to withstand the
physical toll by flying in an aerobatic
plane this is just a hint of what's to
come
a test-run crank the Beast up to a mere
200 miles an hour see how she handles 10
years and 40 million dollars in the
making the man behind the wheel and the
project is Andy green former RAF fighter
pilot who's held the record since 1997
before you could Google land speed
record the call it doesn't leap into the
air and explode
I was delighted to find out it is
possible to drive supersonic and we did
it but if that ride had doors the
Bloodhound is aiming to blow them off
we're not just trying to break the
current record 763 miles an hour in a
satiric we can have an engineering
adventure that will push back the
boundaries of physics literally push
back the boundaries of human endeavor it
will also push the boundaries of the
human body to get a hint of what that
feels like Green took me up in a stunt
plane where he trains his body to take
the whole load of g-forces he'll
experience during a real thing
simulating the exact conditions of the
thousand mile an hour run I was just
hoping it in the pass out
learns to go over full week is a squat G
of acceleration that's 20 miles an hour
per second
eight seconds later we doing 200 miles
an hour now looking for the rocket about
350 firing to walk in we're gonna get
the rocket firing now
second up counting it's another 40 miles
in and out of speed so we're doing
already is the blood rush to my head it
felt like you is about to explode
[Music]
then came the worst part of all
deceleration at three times the force of
gravity another detention stomach touchy
legs in three two one
now 3G deceleration
the gut-wrenching g-force is generated
from tapping into the lunatic fringe
technology pitch at the rolls-royce jet
engine found in the Eurofighter and
mounted it on top of a rocket yes
this is what it looked like in testing
the stats are face-melting least
staggering 25,000 feet the altitude it
would reach if pointed straight in the
air 17 times the height of the Empire
State Building $135,000 every indy500
car on the track combined seven times
over at top speed shall cover a mile in
3.6 seconds more than four football
fields per second face stiff competition
from the United States and a proven 500
mile an hour North American Eagle and
from Australia down under the invader
although still primarily in the planning
stages bloodhound leads the hunt for now
which brings us back to that test run o
sign of nerves as green dances fetching
fire proof onesie it is as fast as this
car has ever gone but the plan is to
reach more than five
the result 210 miles per hour when you
got out of there you're as giddy as I've
seen you exciting day for you we came
here to show just how good this car
isn't just how ready this car is to go
faster the car didn't just do that
doesn't do it it did it in spades the
team is now gearing up to smash their
own world record next year with the
competition choking on the afterburner
the only thing the Bloodhound is chasing
is destiny for CBS this morning Charlie
d'Agata nuki England
Charlie d'Agata yeah it's a rocket with
wheels down